oh the weather today is fantastic I
couldn't have asked for a better day to
be out here on hole number six earlier
we were gonna be on hole number nine and
that might have been a little sunny for
my taste but we've got this great
umbrella oh that was a great shot
we wanted to go measure that hole or
that shot but yes I do enjoy this hole a
lot it does have that beautiful Audi
though I think hole number 16 has be
better out I work with Lara Shelley our
development coordinator and we make all
the fundraising efforts happen so we
reach out to for a corporate support for
philanthropic individuals support we try
to raise funds for the scholastic
initiative which is why we're here today
at Glen Echo we're having a lot of fun
and you know what what's fun about this
is par 3 if you're really not that good
of a golfer you can still have a great
day and we've all been playing pretty
good on certain holes you know and we
nobody's set in the world on fire we
actually we have Aaron here who's doing
all the heavy lifting for us and we're
just kind of riding the waves and having
fun we're gonna be back next year I can
tell you that for sure we'll be
sponsoring there the Chess Club golf
tournament for sure without corporate
dollars we cannot we can't go into as
many schools that as we're in we can't
you know we can't do a lot of things we
do because you know a lot of times
corporations that's where a lot of cell
and traffic money sits so we really need
those funds to go into as many schools
as possible the game of chess is really
making a difference especially to
underserved kids the benefits of the
game are really giving them those
lifelong lessons to make the right moves
in life and to be successful
King deewan so at this particular hole
the Blitz hole hole for teams the
objective is to get the ball into the
hole as quickly as you can so the
players are out here they have some
people teeing off they have other people
down on the green and it's a different
form of strategy it really requires them
to give it some thought and think about
things in a different way than they
normally would you can have as many
hitters as you want that's the strategy
situation it's absolutely true that this
hole is not a traditional golf hole much
in the way that chess isn't your
traditional game being able to reach
outside of our normal boundaries of the
traditional chess player of the people
who are already interested in what's
happening at the club is an opportunity
to reach new audiences it's also an
opportunity for us to show all of the
hard work that we put in to making
scholastic chess successful you know
kids who play chess are smarter they
have better grades they have better
attendance they have better behavior in
the classroom they're able to solve
complex problems more quickly and it's
really important for us because chess is
one of those tools where you can play a
game and at the same time learn those
critical skills that are important for
education
you beat you beat your previous time
every time we have the chance to come
out to Glen Echo it's a great
opportunity the weather has always been
wonderful the staff here are fantastic
and really do an excellent job of
getting amber to everything ready for us
oh hey Ben Moo by the way that is the
shot of the day right there that might
be that might be the winner right here
this might be the winning shot holy cow
that is the first-place shot what a
fantastic show the sponsors the donors
the corporation's the the small
businesses they're the ones who really
make all of this possible and recognize
what the Chess Club is doing in San Luis
is impactful for kids that's the most
important part
you